cayó la noche y así quedaron las calles
de highland park en chicago
carritos de bebé y bicicletas de niño
abandonadas el 4 de julio el día de la
independencia de eeuu volvió a tener un
tiroteo masivo la sociedad una vez más
conmocionada por las víctimas
sobrellevar el duelo de rigor como en el
estadio de los chicago white sox de
béisbol donde hubo un minuto de silencio
el sospechoso fue detenido tras una
corta persecución un joven de 21 años
que habría disparado desde una azotea
antes causó terror entre la población
si solo recuerdo haber visto como humo
en el suelo estábamos literalmente cerca
de donde ocurrió todo recuerdo haber
oído los disparos y luego hacer como y
luego volver a cargar y luego otra vez y
la gente gritando y corriendo fue
realmente traumático y aterrador
más al este otro tiroteo en filadelfia
acerca del concierto por el 4 de julio
una persona no identificada abrió fuego
contra dos policías aunque éstos
sobrevivieron el alcalde mostró su
frustración
este es un país de armas es una locura
somos el país más armado en la historia
mundial y somos uno de los menos seguros
entonces hasta que los estadounidenses
decidan renunciar a las armas ya la
oportunidad de obtenerlas vamos a tener
este problema estoy esperando que pase
algo malo todo el tiempo
40 mil personas al año mueren a causa de
las armas en eeuu su uso llega incluso
al día en el que se celebra su fundación
y los lazos que aún la mantienen unida